the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
morning everyone hope you all had a
great spring break and during which like
hope you can have more of 604 six today
we're going to look at network flow and
two things in network flow
the first one is admins cop over them
after that we are going to look at some
two applications in particular they are
called bipartite matching and cover okay
so we'll start with simpler algorithm
which is for focusing okay someone
remind us what for focusing does
go ahead
it gets rid of it yep what's your name
button
Misha okay so well Misha gave a very
brief description let's be a little more
bit more detailed so we have a graph
network flow G and the first thing one's
going to do is that given a flow it will
transform G from rescue graph everyone
remembers that then ah @fo rhythm will
find a path going from source to sink in
this rescue graph and then augment this
path
augmenting just means increasing the
flow on that path by how much
yeah the minimum edge on the pack let me
just define that to be the capacity of
the path which is the capacity of the
weakest link okay then what's the last
step we're missing here
so after augmenting our flow changed
from F to a front and then we're going
to loop back have a prime then G F prime
by to find a path in G F prime and
continue from there so this algorithm in
some sense is not even a very detailed
algorithm because it doesn't say how to
find a path in the second step and
that's indeed the problem because we
have seen a pathologically bad case
where each capacity is a billion and the
correct way to do it is simply like
augmenting this pack and then that pack
sorry there's a edge one like then we'll
be done but the pathologically bad case
is we keep going through this middle
edge okay so admin Cup is an improvement
to this algorithm let me just ready here
it's its first step third and fourth
steps are actually exactly the same no
change from both focus on the only thing
it does is that it finds a special path
did Sweeney cover this in lecture that's
what path edmonds-karp line I see some
people nodding okay go ahead
okay does everyone agree with that so
add one Karp finds the shortest path
from I guess can you see that pot nope
I'm sorry about that
financial days the path here I show this
just means least number of hops here in
this pathologically bad example add one
cup will do much better because it will
find this path instead of this weird
path right because that path is distance
is two and the one going across the
middle is three okay now we are going to
prove that this algorithm runs in order
ve square so okay so one step back do we
have to prove that is correct
that it indeed finds the maximum flow
yeah I don't I claim I don't have to do
that because it's the same thing as 44%
you can find any pad now we want to show
we want to bound this runtime so any
idea high-level idea how we are going to
do that in which several steps
okay so okay a simpler question what's
the what's the complexity of this second
step find the shortest path from source
to sink
Oh oui plus e and in this case actually
V is always less than simply say Oh V
now how long does it take to augment
that path if we have found it Oh V
that's correct
but I claim I we can say we can also say
it's all V because the short is the path
at least have at most as we hops and
then from F to F Prime
okay so I think in some sense these two
are the same steps also of V and then
updating the rescue graph is also all
three so one of this iteration each
iteration takes how long or V right this
is the most expensive step in one
iteration okay so what else do we have
to do to prove this bound we need to
show that the number of iterations is of
the time see if we can show that
now we are pretty much done okay
okay now to prove that bound we first
need a lemma which we call monotonic
so let me define Delta FV
this is
the length of the shortest path from s
from the source to V which is a node in
a graph the length of that in residue
graph of F
is that definition clear
and this lemma says Delta FB for any
vertex V does not decrease okay so it
can only monotonically in our increases
okay we're going to prove that
so we're proof by contradiction assume
this is not a case that means there is
some V but in F prime which is the new
rescue graph is shortest path from the
source in the new rescue graph is less
than the old one right that's we are
going to derive a contradiction to them
but so there may be many such vertices
that drop I'm but if there if there is
any I'm going to define V to be the one
with smallest Delta in F Prime
okay any questions about this step
so there could be like we 1 V 2 V 3 that
or make this happen I'm going to choose
the one among those that has the
smallest distance from the source
okay
now here's our my sauce we have a path
to eat in in graph G F Prime
right so this is a path then I can
always find the predecessor which will
COI which I'll call you here
if this is the shortest path to V what
can I say about Delta V and butter of
you what can I say about these two
quantities
and it
this one is greater than that
one of them is greater than the other
that's always children for any - Connie
okay meter set V is U plus one does that
make sense to everyone
that's the shortest path to V it goes
through you
that's correct
so because I okay maybe I wasn't clear
about that I define you to be these
predecessor on the show these two paths
okay
then definitely ah Delta F prime of V is
the other prime the other F prime u plus
one okay
now I'll use you to be my steps tone
back to the original graph F I want to
say something about this quantity and
Delta u in graph F what can I say about
that
it mean
this is a tricky part
this one is greater than that or the
entire 10 is greater than that
okay I'm going to claim this one is
greater than Delta of U plus 1by which
I'm claiming this quantity is larger
than that
can anyone give a reason why I can claim
that
so recall how I defined the
good question so V so there are several
probably several of these that have
Delta F prime less than Delta F I'm
going to define V to be this be the one
with smallest Delta F among all those
nodes that have a job in Delta in Delta
this is probably a tricky part then by
definition since Delta fu is less than
Delta LV right and I defined V to be the
to be the one with the smallest Delta
that satisfy that so all the use so U is
the predecessor of V so you shouldn't be
one of those nodes who that have a job
in Delta in Delta right so I know this
is probably a tricky part and I'll stop
for questions and make sure we resolve
this part before we move on
how many people get it okay only two
that's not good okay
as well as the
smaller
okay so okay may be to be the smallest
the one with smallest f such that Delta
F prime is less than Delta okay okay
maybe that's that's why I can't do this
to you guys sorry about that so we have
a bunch of notes who have a job in Delta
and I define V to be the one amount that
has the smallest at Delta F prime
question
okay Delta F R of a node is the shortest
path from source to that node in G of F
which is the rescue graph given a flow
right so f is well some flow and F prime
is the flow after we augment in a
certain path so f prime is one step
after F okay how many people get that
now still not everyone
Hey any questions about that
I'm how many people I still haven't got
that okay so some people it's like
Schrodinger's cat in the middle state
oh then I'll have to move on and I'll
assume you all get this get that one has
the lastest up so of course we will ask
what's the relation between this guy and
Delta F of V because final occurs in the
end we want to show we want to show a
contradiction that Delta FV is probably
greater or equal to Delta F of V this is
another tricky part so let me ask our
maybe simpler question now so that is
our G of F prime so we also have G of F
it has the source some you here V there
sink there that's this edge exist in
this graph
so I know it that actually exists
because I defined you to be the
predecessor of V right but you V is in
that graph doesn't necessarily mean you
V is in the old graph so it could
certainly exist but is it possible that
this edge didn't exist how many people
will say ah that edge definitely exists
how many people would say maybe it
doesn't exist
it doesn't matter because we can prove
both cases so let's say case one UV is
indeed in the original graph G of F in
that case can I say something about that
last step
that
greater or equal to none of e okay
why is that
the shirt is about to be there
correct does everyone get that
so the shortest path in this graph to V
is not necessarily this one right but if
it's some other one okay so in case one
I'm assuming this edge exists right then
no matter what the shortest path is it's
definitely shorter than I first go to
from s to U and then you to be right the
shortest path between s to V is
definitely shoulder then I first go from
s to u and then u to V make sense
okay so case one done is a contradiction
because we showed that the F prime of V
is greater or equal to Delta F of Li any
questions about that
okay case two UV is not in 2gf okay so
how can that even happen is it possible
that this edge didn't exist
and
okay great point that's exactly right so
it is possible that this edge didn't
exist but only appeared after we go from
F to F Prime
how can that happen that must mean we
are augmenting a path that goes right
through it right but this edge doesn't
exist so we cannot be augmenting a path
that crossed this way we must be
augmenting a path that goes like that
right first from s to V and then V to
you and then you to T if we are all
menteng such a path then we are going to
remove this edge from V to u but we will
add u to V to the next graph okay
did everyone get that
so now here more formally I'm going to
claims if we assume UV is not in G of F
and we also know UV is in G F Prime what
does that mean these two can only be
caused by the fact that UV is in GF f gr
G of F not only in that graph it must be
under ah it must be on the path we are
augmenting
make sense
okay so given that can we say something
about dot F of you and out of a V
so here is our P like this this entire
thing here
and P is the augmenting path
correct right so if that is the augment
impact in admin Corp we are looking for
the shortest path right so V is the
predecessor of U then Delta of U is
Delta V plus 1 that means that quantity
here is Delta F of V plus 2 okay
so it's also a contradiction to what we
assumed
and so that proves the our lemma of
every nodes Delta monotonically
increases now here I'm going to show
that our final theorem that we have at
most ve number of iterations so the way
we're going to show that is we're going
to show we are going to define a
capacity of the path it must be the
capacity of this weakest link we're
going to define its wickets the link is
UV okay and we're going to show that UV
will call that critical edge we are
going to show UV can be critical only of
V times if that if that holds for every
edge then I claim all the edges combined
can only be augmented of the e times
now
how do we show that
so again
let's assume we are all meant in a path
from that goes through you to be if we
do that by our algorithm we will get rid
of this path right and have an edge
backwards when we go from F to some
other F Prime
now when can I all mint UV again it can
only happen if at some point I come back
to augment the path going from V to u by
n because that will eliminate this back
back edge and and add back our edge UV
okay let's see what happens there now
let I'll call this graph F this graph F
Prime
so you have Prime we know we are all
menteng the path from V to u by the same
argument Delta u is Delta V plus one in
F Prime
correct and we know this one doesn't
drop right so it's greater or equal than
Delta F of V plus one okay and we also
know being F V is the predecessor of U
so this one is equal to Delta f of U
plus two what does that mean it means in
between two times u v is argument is
augmented Delta of U must increase by at
least two
then how large can Delta of a certain
node possibly be
it's definitely bounded by awfully right
bounded by V so then I claim this
particular edge UV can only be involved
can only be critical power edge of V
times actually half of V times strictly
so then every edge combined there can
only be half of V times a number of
augmentation
okay any questions about that part about
the entire proof
if not well below
okay this is not part of the required in
the recitation but I'll quickly say a
few words about a unit value algorithm
Teaneck which one C of V square
I'm Z so this is an improvement to admin
Corp and its idea is that I'm going to
find all the showed is the path in one
go from s to T okay
I'm going to augment all of them at the
same time then because they are all
shortest paths when I augmented each
path will be broken right maybe I'll get
with this edge this edge and that edge
and the thesis is that the shortest path
will increase here the shortest path is
three but I have destroyed or the
shortest path of line three so I'm going
to show this pattern for if they do that
you can bound a number of iterations to
of V because your shortest path can Oh
long can be at most V but how each
iteration is slightly more complicated
because you need to find all the
shortest paths in happens that they can
show you can find it in the times e that
gives the v square V okay that's not the
important part
and the more interesting part is that
actually the author of this algorithm is
his name is TD's but his algorithm is
very hard to understand that well nobody
yeah nobody got that and there is some
other guy whom whose name is I think
it's given he understood the problem and
started advertising to people and giving
lectures on deenis algorithm so he
popularized popularized algorithm but
unfortunately he got the name of the
author wrong and so that's why this
algorithm is henceforth called Linux
algorithm this is useful to know why
because you can tell this story to other
people so they will assume that you know
a lot about in X algorithm well in fact
you
probably don't and that's exactly what
I'm doing here okay now let's look at
one application bipartite matching
ah okay so the problem is done we have
like several person and several tasks
let me get rid of the one person I don't
want to do that nice stuff so we have a
graph like that and each edge if there's
a edge that means this person is capable
of performing that task and the problem
is that find the matching which means
the assignment from people to tasks such
that we get as many tasks done as
possible okay so one person can only do
one task and one task only needs one
person so here you can see a bad
matching which is I will sign this first
guy to task one then no one can do the
task - right so if I am smarter how
assign one of these guys to that task
and have this person handle the other
task it's the problem creep so this is
caught by pothole graph because a well
which means you can partition a graph
into two parts and within each part
there is no edge connecting any pair of
vertices and you can also define this
problem for general graph
the goal is the same that find a subset
of edges such that no two edges are
connected to the same vertex so we're
going to look at bipartite graph and we
claim in bipartite graph this can be
solved using max-flow I'll give you one
minute to think about that how to come
transform that problem to a max flow
problem
any ideas
okay okay I will add a sauce here and a
sink there and I'll have create these
edges okay how do I restrict the
capacity of all the edges such that I
can guarantee no like each person is no
person is taking two tasks and no task
is assigned to two people
I make all of them wait one okay we do
that one one one one one and everything
here is wait one then that's that me
correct what was the name Colleen okay
if we do that then well because each
person only has one incoming edge oh
sorry maybe I should have shown the
arrows here each person only has one
incoming edge so it cannot take care of
two tasks at the same time right same
thing for each task it's only it only
has one outgoing edge so it cannot be
taken care of by multiple people okay so
if we find if the max-flow is K that
means we can find
that the max matching is also K we can
get K tasks done it's very easy to see
because we can have a cut here and if
the max flow is K that clearly K tags
are taken care of okay
any question about that
find assignment from people to task to
get as many tasks done as possible so
how many tasks can we handle okay so I'm
doing a different topic from the
recitation note in the recitation notes
we are considering another problem
called
buy pot I'll cover which is exactly the
same thing as that
so cover also bipartite graph is defined
to us let's find several vertices in
this graph such that each node at least
okay let me color several nodes in this
graph such that each edge is connected
to at least one dark node and this that
nodes are colored is called a cover I
want to find a minimum cover if you can
of course if you can of course cover all
the nodes that's trivial hijos but we
are looking for the minimum cover and
the claim is that mean cover is k if and
only if max flow sorry ah max matching
okay
why is that because in that matching if
we have a matching then we have a set of
disjoint edges right no two edges are
connecting to the same note so if we
want to cover these edges we at least
have to add one of this guy want to
color one of these two and one of these
two right so if we have K matching edges
then we at least need K nodes to cover
them for example I can call a cup cover
them like that
but this is not a foolproof because I
also need to show I can indeed find a
cover that that is K
let me think about what I should prove
that
okay I'm going to give it a try you
don't get that that's fine
okay cover cover is a set of notes such
that every edge in a graph is connected
to at least one of the note in a cover
okay so this is not a cover because this
edge is not covered
know so in this case I probably have to
add that as well but clearly there is a
better cover even a smaller cover which
is those two right yeah
so how are we going to transform that
matching to cover so let me go first
give a matching here one max matching
should be something like this I have
this edge and one of those two that is a
matching right now that is a max
matching
no question about that so let me get rid
of all these one way to transform this
into a cover is that I will first color
these two guys I'll color the nodes on
the left where they are connected to a
matching edge right after that I'm going
to start from this one and jump between
notes taking alternating path meaning
I'll take a unmatched edge and then take
a match the edge and then take an
unmatched edge again but there's no such
thing
and
okay and if I take this jump I was swap
them make that starch
okay this graph is a little strange
okay now I claim this is a cover its
that yeah that is one right and if there
is another like unmatched edge going out
then I'll keep taking that alternate
alternating path but I have to stop
because there's no such edge anymore how
can I say oh I can improve what can I
claim this is a cover so clearly this is
if this is a cover then is a cover of
size K right so it's we have proved the
entire thing then we are going to
consider several things separately so
I'm going to first claim if I have a
match to edge then it's definitely
covered because ah one of its endpoints
is dark right we only do a switching
between dark and white if it is in the
if it's a matched edge itself right so I
only need to show that there this thing
doesn't happen there is a edge that's
unmatched and two of its end points are
both white okay I'm going to first claim
this node cannot have a match edge
because if it does then this is
alternating path and I'm going to switch
that switch these two okay make sense
okay so this doesn't exist
it can only have unmatched edge now what
can I say about this note I claim this
note needs at least one match to edge
because if it doesn't right then I
should act this guy into my matching it
doesn't violate anyone a constraint I
didn't add that because there is
probably a match the edge connecting to
this guy then I'm going to so then this
guy has to be dark because this one is
not then how did this one become dark it
must come from some other guy on the
left right so there is alternating path
going back and forth
something like this there is an
alternating path starting from left but
ends here because we showed that this
guy is not connecting to any matched
edges in that case what I'm going to do
is I'll match this edge match this edge
match this edge and I'll match these two
edges and that's a larger matching so I
remove the two I added three
that means a max matching of K leads to
minimum cover of K as well which also
means a max flow of K in our network
flow okay so this part this equivalence
is not required you should know this
proof the proof of that mon-cock and
know that matching and cover can be
solved by network flow and that Dinis
name is spelled not as Teaneck okay and
that's everything for today